reading the rating is always difficult
king of the nil
i even lost to this guy oh seriously
okay
we surely need
you know to beat him
what do i do now
i'm just curious
this cannot be good
so he just takes
he just takes now
and doesn't look smart to me
so
well i think curiosity killed the cat
so i feel now
very curious what's going on here
hopefully i want to i want to follow
cat's footsteps
or uh
to be more correct
post steps
let's go on g5
what is this move come on queen d3
so after bishop d6 i wonder if i go even
for f4
or it's
somewhat too much
knight before
uh doesn't look too smart to me
let me just queen g3 and then queen g2
just very solid to put my queen so close
to the king so i never
i will never ever get tricked that's
kind of very important in such positions
to feel safe
so let's uh
return to the chat i kind of
kind of missed something here
he just goes q6 so we think
we retreat
maybe he checks on c2 but okay then even
bishop v6 is winning now by the way
bishop bishop v6 is a nice touch
i like it
so he was all about giving me a mate but
somehow i was
i was the first to create things
so let's take the bishop
why did i take the bishop no idea
turns out it's not a mate
at least for now
so then let's go b1
uh let's be
modest
94
what's this knight five
why the game is even
is even on
tell me
please
what do you think about collapse like uh
hickory with people
well
why do you
you know
why do you think i have my my opinion on
let's say on everything
i'm not so
you know up to up to dated and all these
things
okay let's go for some meeting making
that
might be six is the idea
one of the many ideas to deliver mate
here
no he resigned
sensational
so i equalize this call with this guy
thank you